Sw-precache works well with either Gulp
or Grunt or any other built screen.
I personally, tend towards Gulp so
I'll show you that, but
the same process applies for Grunt.
Since I already have a simple Gulp
file to build parts of my project,
I first need to install sw-precache.
Great, done.
Next I need to add sw-precache
to my Gulp file and
add a new task to build
the service worker.
Sw-precache takes two parameters,
the location where I want it to
write the service-worker to, and
the options I want it to use.
Specifying the staticFileGlobs,
tells it where we wanted to pre-cache
any files that match the Glob.
You can also specify runtimeCaching
options, which will cache
any other network request, specifically
the request to the weather API.
You can see here I've created my
task to generate the service worker,
and I pass it the two parameters.
The location where I want it
to write the service file to,
and the parameters I want it to use
to generate the service worker.